la cena il y a des deux papas 1-2 papin
quand je dis tu es deux papas ya ton
vrai papa est ton papa de soda il est
cloué au fond de moi je pense est vrai
ton vrai papa et guy trois coups bas ils
se connaissent ils sont vus déjà et de
papara ça me paraîtrait moins probable
que passe partout en ramasser et
franchement tu penses vraiment que ton
père ton père maintenir son plateau
ouais mon père il peut venir ou pas
pourquoi on vient on perd il bien
tranquille je connais pas ça bah écoute
[Applaudissements]
au contraire
bah oui on va mais venez là alors
mettons emmènera à côté de dominer cause
kkb toi côté cote est pas comment
va-t-on pas toi et vas-y vas-y mal an on
fait alors on fait andré geignard banc
par le grand rabbin ces mini rabat et ça
fait plaisir de voir le papa de quelques
mots ça va ça va bien c'est fait
franchement je crois jamais j'aurais cru
que vous allez venir
et ben voilà ça ou ça vous fait plaisir
de devoir débarquer sur un plateau bien
vous le voyez tout le temps là mais se
voit régulièrement
c'était toujours très drôle qu'on le
voit on voit quelqu'un sur un plateau
c'est un live s'il vous plaît est ce que
quelqu'un je peux juste prendre cette
vidéo pour moi pour me glisser un
comédien pour moi c'est un des plus
grands comédiens français l'exceptionnel
est exceptionnel c'est très dur d'en
recevoir des compliments murs mais j'te
jure guy tu sais que moi je te suis oui
est-ce que tu étais sur france 2 oui je
te suivent et jeter ouf de toi déjà
rêver et après bon après cette attaque
je remercie et un amour de mercy avec
son papa dans ce cas oui si on parle de
soda tu te souviens quand il était venu
sur le plateau il avait fait un sketch à
je me rappelle très bien la merde tu te
souviens de tout non je me rappelle que
je crois qu'elle jouait pas d'acteur
porno jouer cyril a joué un acteur porno
alors on n'a pas lésiné non c'est très
chiant veuille pas l'oeuvre non plus
fort et tu as raison on ne voyait pas le
droit non plus mais c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai que c'est bien je suis
content que vous avez invité guiche
content de pouvoir le mettre en lumière
ainsi que mon papa bien entendu mais
guise et c'est un des meilleurs acteurs
français depuis
mais c'est vrai que plus attention à ce
que tu dis de mais là il est tout dégât
des eaux
on mesure a été tournée j'attends depuis
rentrée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sa rivale sarcelles à la demi heure
c'est lourd c'est lourd jamais d'accord
pourquoi vous avez conservant un acteur
porno j'ai pas compris
ouais parce que vous faites un peu non
mais c'est vrai cyril vous fait un peu
froid intense a fait le tekken et je
m'en souviens mais ce l'est avait choisi
de le faire
t'étais pas t'es pas du tout étonnée
qu'il tempère sur le plateau mais non
parce que mon père depuis que depuis je
suis tout petit c'est lui qui m'a incité
à faire tu vois le rigolo à l'époque de
attention à la marche déjà elle était
venue avec moi
voilà quand je sais que s'il pouvait
venir avec moi sur scène ou sur les
plateaux
il a le bagout nécessaire il a le vous
avez toujours cru que le gabarit est
nécessaire quoi oui tout de suite n'ai
jamais douté non tu sens qu'il a des
réponses étayées
[Rires]
cette fois on fait quoi dans la vie vous
monsieur le sua dams monsieur adams je
travaille dans l'immobilier d'accord
immobilière pour d'accord un batailleur
il vend un trois-pièces votre prénom
thierry thierry may a attiré moi j'aime
bien il a un prénom ça ça passe partout
qui arrive est thierry guille merci en
tout cas la boue rester un petit peu
avec nous